[Music]
ethan joins us in phoenix arizona ethan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going great how can we help
today
good i'm so glad you guys took my calls
it's crazy that i'm even [ __ ] you
guys so i decided to tell you um
i'm calling because i'm getting married
in two months
congrats brother awesome yeah
thank you thank you thank you
and my
i guess you can say girlfriend's
father-in-law he has a little bit of
trouble with money and it makes me
really sad because he makes
pretty good money for
being
he makes good money and whatever but i
just wanted to know like boundary-wise
and
um what's where's my standpoint like how
can i help him
being his son-in-law help him with his
money like do i say something or
what do you guys think
never under any circumstances ever
not your circus not your monkey not your
job
your job is to take care of your wife to
love her to co-create an incredible home
and financial legacy and
create a remarkable household that's
going to be make you good neighbors and
good community members and good citizens
and
good church members whatever you're all
going to do with your life but your
father-in-law's life is your
father-in-law's life if he ever takes
you out for breakfast one day and says
hey man tell me about the
this way you guys are doing this great
um but no it's not your job man
the best thing you can do is live your
life publicly in such a way where he's
like whoa you guys did what you can pay
cash for cars yeah how did you do that
that's the only way he's going to take
any advice from you
okay you're about to say something what
the reason i ask is because he is going
through like a divorce in his life he
married someone who was
keeping on the books but um
i i'm expecting the question to come up
pretty soon because
recently in my adult life he's seen the
way that i treat money in the way that i
save up and stuff and
we're really open with money but to him
so he sees the way that we
you know
live our lives of money i
sense a question or a concern from him
coming soon about how he can do the same
thing because
he
talks all the time about how he
never has enough money or he
he just lives paycheck to paycheck and
whatnot so i was just wondering when the
question does come from him i would
never really just be like hey you got to
do this money i was more
wanting to know when the question arises
from him
what can i say
for a wedding present ethan we're going
to send you a copy of total money
makeover and i want you just to hold it
and if that question ever comes up
i want you to tell your father-in-law
read this book
and if you have questions after this
book you and i will go grab coffee and
you can look at them and smile and say
you're paying
and um i'll talk to you about how we do
this
and for sure let um let the book it's a
step-by-step process and we're going to
give it to you for a wedding gift um and
let that book be the entry point because
what you don't want to do
is create a well i know what you should
be doing with your father-in-law he's
already gonna have enough problems with
you man you're marrying his daughter for
crying out loud so yeah keep the peace
it sounds like you're anticipating
something because you want him to ask
you
and you have the what you think is the
right answer and you can't wait to give
it to him and what i want to tell you
brother let that go
his money is the way he's chosen to
handle his money that's it that's his
circus man
and as guide a guy as um
husband to almost husband to
about to be new family members he sits
down and says hey let's talk hand him
that book and say we'll we'll follow up
later but man stay out of that business
man because you're
like like george said
you do you proselytize to the world by
how you live your life right that's
going to be the the loudest most
beautiful way you can communicate this
message absolutely and i think one once
it is solicited it's a different
conversation you can do that with grace
you've been invited in right yeah and
you're not going to do with judgment i
can hear it in your voice that you
really do want to help him and so i
think once that day comes absolutely
grab coffee and show them how you did it
that's it and you don't have to say
you're you're doing terrible financially
and i can help you're just showing him
the tools that you used as well i just
can't i'm trying to just imagine if i'd
called my father-in-law a week after my
after my honeymoon and been like hey
all right so here's a couple of things
you're doing wrong with your money and
that wouldn't have gone well yeah that's
so hard with family
yeah you want them to win you want to
love them yeah um and
that's not your circus yep